you
hey guys today I'm going to show you
five quick ways you can make your cheesy
plots look better and you can go from
something like this into something like
this
so let's get started so I've got this
data frame called avocado data I'm gonna
go ahead and open that up and you can
see we've got three columns here that
date a region and an average price so my
goal is to build a ggplot that looks
good but shows the average prices over
time by these five different regions so
I'm gonna go back to our code and start
building out our plot we're gonna grab
our avocado data frame we're gonna pipe
that into the ggplot function set our
aesthetics so the date is on the x-axis
the average price is on the y axis and
we're gonna color by that region
variable so we get five different lines
and then we just need to add one more
layer which is the GM line to show that
this is going to be a line plot so if we
go ahead and run this you can see we get
this pretty basic plot doesn't look too
impressive so that brings us to number
one which is going to be adding labels
to our plot and by labels I mean titles
subtitles axes titles etc this is the
easiest single fix you can do to improve
your plots and I recommend overwriting
any of the axes that you see that use
variable names like this average price
right here just because it might be
confusing to your viewer so to add our
labels we're gonna go ahead and add
another layer to our plot called labs
and we're gonna pass in a title a
subtitle and X for our x axis Y for our
y axis and a color which we'll rename
this legend right here now if we had a
box plot and we wanted to cover the
different box plots this would be fill
equals region and again this would be
filled down here if we wanted to rename
that legend but because we're coloring
these lines and it's a color we're gonna
go ahead and name this region just like
that so if we go ahead and run this you
can see that we now have some labels on
our graph and it looks already a lot
better and it's a lot more clear what
we're looking at so now let's move on to
tip number two which is setting a theme
for our plot now we could build our own
theme from the ground up but there are a
lot of themes already out there so let's
just use one of those
the ggplot library
actually has some themes by default but
there's another library called GG themes
so we're gonna load that in and if you
don't have this you just have to install
that packages GG themes with quotes
around GG themes once we load this in we
should gain access to all the themes
within that library so here are a couple
of themes from GG themes you can see
that there are a lot of options the one
I like to use is called 538 from the 538
website so we'll go ahead back to our
code and add another layer called theme
538 and if we run this you can see that
it kind of changed up our background it
moved the legend down here so it does a
lot for us which is a lot easier than
having to rewrite the theme from the
ground up but it did remove the X and y
axis titles so in order to add those
back in we just need to add another
argument after this cult theme which
will essentially modify any kind of
visual changes with your graph and axis
title which were the elements that
disappeared they were set to blank by
this 538 theme we want to make sure that
those text appears so we're gonna add
element text I know we rerun this you
see that we get back the date and the
average price titles that we added
before and now we can move on to tip
number three which is emphasizing your
data essentially you want to make your
data really visible because by default
the lines on ggplot are kind of thin
they're hard to see and in addition if
there's any data you want to stand out
we're gonna do that so so there are
three ways we're gonna emphasize our
data the first is making the lines
thicker right now they're kind of thin
the second is adding some opacity so
making some of these lines a bit more
transparent and the third is using
different line types to differentiate
our data so let's say theoretically I
wanted to highlight this North East line
the yellow line at the top one thing I
could do is keep this line solid but
make the four other lines dotted so
let's do that first thing and start by
making the lines thicker this is pretty
easy we just need to give up back to the
G on line and change the size to 1.5 and
we also want to like I mentioned had
some opacity to our lines so we're gonna
change the Alpha to 0.8 if we run this
you can see it makes those two changes
and now we're these lines overlap you
can see that they actually do overlap
each other and the lines are going
through each other and then I just
wanted to use different line types to
differentiate our data so let's do that
really quick now the way we have to do
this is actually we need to add a new
column to our avocado data frame so the
ggplot can distinguish the northeast
region from the for other regions now
the easiest way to do this is right
after our avocado data line we're gonna
use this deep liar library to call the
mutate function which essentially adds a
new column just right on to our data
frame and this new column is going to be
called is North East and we're just
going to check for the condition where
this region column is equal to North
East and that's super simple we just
need to write region equals equals North
East and then we can just pipe this into
our ggplot function now once we've
created this new is North East condition
we're gonna go down to our GM one and
say yes to call our aesthetic line type
equals is North East and now it'll know
to differentiate based on our two
different groups is north east is true
or is North East is false and then the
last last thing we need to do is add
another argument down here called scale
line type manual this gives us access to
these different types of lines and we're
gonna pass in values equals C dashed and
then solid essentially if we didn't have
this line even though the ggplot knows
that the Northeast is different from
these four other lines it would still
keep them all solid because we're not
really telling it to do anything so by
passing in dashed and solid it's gonna
take all those values that are false so
these four lines down here and make them
dash lines and keep the top one the
Northeast one that's true solid now if
we run this that looks pretty good we've
got our dashed lines down here but I
don't really want this legend to show up
so I'm also gonna pass in another
that says guide equals none and now when
I run this it should remove that one
legend while keeping our color legend
down here now we're gonna move on to tip
number four which is adding color to our
ggplot now by default there are some
ggplot colors that are included I'm not
a huge fan of them so we're gonna change
that up my graph is about avocados so
I'd love to get some avocado colors or
earth tones into this craft and I have a
couple of options of doing that I could
either find a color palette in this list
of ggplot color palettes or we can go to
chrome search for color picker and then
pick out five colors and get their hex
values so let's say theoretically I like
this set one colors all I need to do is
add an argument down here called scale
color Brewer and how it would be set one
now again because this is a line plot
and I'm coloring by the region you're
gonna have to use scale color Brewer but
if this was a box plot we would be
filling by the region and this would be
scale filbert so it's important to note
that distinction but if I run this it'll
change up my colors into this color
palette but I'm not a huge fan so I'm
gonna go ahead and pick some manual
colors and now my pace of those colors
right up here so I'm just gonna call
this my colors you can see it's just a
simple vector that I've concatenated
just a few strings I'm gonna run this my
colors command to create it and now
instead of doing this scale color Brewer
using one of the predefined color
palettes I'm gonna write scaled color
manual and the values is gonna be this
my colors variable that I've created so
if I run this you can see these are the
colors I've chosen and I think you just
much better goes with the data that I'm
trying to present so we're almost at the
end I'm gonna give you the fifth and
final tip which is changing the font of
your ggplot now this is the minimal
change but it can give your plot a lot
more character so I'm going to use the
help of another library called an
extra-fine and I'm gonna load that in
and if you again if you don't have this
package you just need to install the
packages extra font with the quotes in
quite surrounded the first time you load
in this library you need to call it this
command fine underscore import this will
take some time to run but it essentially
load in all your system fonts into R so
you can use them I've already done that
once you've loaded in the response you
can see what you have by calling these
fonts commands and it'll show you in
your console all the installed fonts you
have so I want to try using this Rubik
font I think that would look pretty cool
on my graph now all we need to do to use
this font on our ggplot is modify the
theme so when we added this theme 538
you can see a change from that other
font to Helvetica and just like we
modify the theme by adding back our axes
we can modify the font by writing text
equals element text family equals Rubik
and this is the font I want to use but
again you can use any font that's
installed down here let's go ahead and
run that and I think this plot looks way
better than what we started with so just
to summarize the five ways to make your
GG plots look better you need to add
some labels set a theme make the data
standout change the colors and change
the font these five things are
relatively easy to do but together they
can turn a really basic looking ggplot
into something a lot more professional
and clean so that pretty much wraps up
this video if you found these tips
helpful I definitely appreciate a like
and subscribe to the channel for more
content like this
thanks for watching and I'll catch you
in the next one